do you want to go first I decided to
like kind of go for like smallish once
so my two challenges was the first one
was really easy I had to go up to a
store clerk and asked if they had boku
no pico much which they said they didn't
thank God but they know what it was
well the guy wasn't English speaking
stuff so he's like is that the one where
the two guys [ __ ] you'll see it in
the video but the other challenge was
really easy it was just pick a figurine
that either myself gone okano likes so
obviously I went with the one that I
liked so that's [ __ ] by the line
spilling glad robbed right here so I'm
gonna unwrap this [ __ ] but I obviously
got my goddamn wife again Monica oh yes
of course it is Oh course it is look if
I'm gonna be on this show casually like
all the freaking time [ __ ] horse okay
I need it to get my wife is she no but I
actually don't even have this one at
home so I guess I'm gonna go I'm just
gonna go next now because of course I
followed my heart as well so yeah III
knew Joey would get a Shinobu figure cuz
I saw so many boxes that were just
purely Shinobu and I'm just like get
that [ __ ] out of me get that [ __ ] out of
my face man you might need to like hold
up to the camera because they might have
it assisted with the boxes in the way
actually yeah so I mean like what I
tried to do at a stop was at the
beginning I just tried to get I just
tried to no down as many figures as I
could for under 20 bucks because I feel
I feel like anything over anything
over 20 bucks was like kind of risking
its in terms of I mean especially if
you're buying like seven figurines
exactly exactly so this one's I don't
have I don't have this figure because
this short test and you gara oh that's
cute that's dude I personally find this
short hair central gaara's figurine so
much nicer than the long head one there
was so many good center gar figurines so
it like hurts me that I had to buy the
cheapest one are boys
I bought them
[Music]
this is a there was a nine hundred yen
sold out online yet like the good soil
it was the cheapest sort online figure
because you know if you're gonna buy
garbage why why care about which you
know terrible item it is it was 900 yen
I think and it was the cheapest short
online figure oh damn was this for a
challenge yeah remember I had to shout I
freaking love Sao while buying an SEO
agency I will say that that's shout
wasn't a shouted that was a in Japanese
culture that was like full it was like
it was just it was like a gradual
building volume let's get this boy out
of him okay the other two though that I
bought I think is super freaking cool
because they're two figurines that I
posted a really wanted but also sorry
just like I think it goes without saying
don't listen to the audio or only of
this it's gonna sound probably this is
box opening ASM okay let me show you the
other two I got okay this second one I
got is a show ninja oh that's so cool
that's pretty far that's right like I'd
never seen this before and I'm like I
was like does this count as a figurine
yeah yeah that's a piece of you know
solid I mean I love shown a job and
that's gonna look so cool and like the
Shelf that's I think if we had a cool
this item award because I didn't know if
we could get a cool this item is you all
agree yeah yeah but I think we can all
agree this is the cool one of the course
figuring yeah and the other one I got is
also pretty cool it's puck from berserk
that's cool how much was that this is
980 yen oh wow cuz every Buzzard figure
I saw was so expensive